if you look at the neuroscience the way
that we're wired has a profound effect
on how we hear and respond to feedback
now we took a look at three variables
that are particularly important in terms
of your reaction to feedback the first
is your baseline in the literature this
is called setpoint sometimes it's served
how happy or unhappy are you in the
absence of other events in your life
where's that level that you come back to
if it's a scale of 1 to 10
some people just live their lives at 9
right they're just so unbelievably happy
and cheerful about everything like from
a cup of coffee to a promotion they're
just thrilled this research comes from
looking at lottery winners a year later
they're about as happy or unhappy as
they were before they won the lottery
and people who go to jail a year or
later they're about as happy or unhappy
as before they went to jail now the
reason this matters for feedback is if
you particularly if you have a low set
point or baseline positive feedback can
be muffled for you the volume is turned
down it's harder for you to hear it now
we look at the second variable which is
swing when you get positive or negative
feedback how far off your baseline does
it knock you the same piece of feedback
can be devastating for one person and
you know kind of annoying for another
and then the third variable is how long
does it take you to come back to your
baseline how long do you sustain
positive feeling or how long does it
take you to recover from negative
feeling so taken together that's where
the big variation in sensitivity comes
from that some people are extremely
sensitive and other people are pretty
insensitive or maybe I should say even
keel
but I suppose if you're insensitive you
don't really care what I call you so it
doesn't matter here's why this is
particularly important there are two
reasons one is your own footprint or
feedback profile not only influences how
you receive feedback it also influences
how you give feedback so if you're
pretty even keel it could be that you're
more likely to be pretty direct or other
people would describe you as harsh in
your feedback because you think like
this isn't that big a deal and you're
overreacting to it other people who are
very sensitive are likely to tiptoe
around issue
and if they're talking to someone who's
pretty even keel like they're not even
understanding that you're giving them
feedback right like you have to be
pretty direct to even get through to
them
the second reason it matters is that
particularly if you swing negative it
can actually distort your sense of the
feedback itself and your sense of
yourself so in terms of distorting your
sense of the feedback itself it's almost
like it super-sizes it you know one
piece of feedback triggers sort of an
overwhelming flood where the feedback
itself overruns its borders it's not one
thing it's everything it's not now it's
forever and you can fall into what we've
called the Google bias
it's as if mentally and emotionally you
google everything that's wrong with me
and you get like 1.2 million hits all
your past mistakes failed relationships
bad judgment you know there are
sponsored ads from your father and your
ex and it's suddenly everything you can
see about yourself the challenge in the
book is how do you dismantle the
distortions so that you can see the
feedback itself at actual size and it
doesn't become so big and overwhelming
that you're actually not in a place to
learn and you're not hearing the
feedback for what it does represent and
what it doesn't represent